[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les footballeurs français ont
certainement vu tous les films
d'hitchcock le suspense en effet n'a
plus de secret pour eux durant 45
minutes ils ont rendu cardiaque les
40000 spectateurs du stade de colombes
on est très tendue dans les tribunes
comme dans un film d'épouvanté et
pourtant c'est par un happy end que va
se terminer ce petit scénario des
maillots français de l'équipe de france
envahissent le camp des joueurs bulgares
suspense là encore un tir sur la barre
transversale ils viennent on oui
yp entre eux et il m'apprend beaucoup de
but voici le deuxième but signé jean
bien que marcel
[Applaudissements]
encore un peu de suspense avant d'en
terminer même scénario tout à leurs
fontaines tir sur la barre la balle
revient but quand même 3 0 pour la
france
le point final dans les filets
le roi gustave ador a présidé à
stockholm une cérémonie solennelle
l'académie royale de suède remettait à
ses lauréats les prix nobel
le poète saint john perse qui fut
ambassadeur sous le nom d'alexis léger
il trouvait cette année le couronnement
de son oeuvre
[Musique]
avec lui les lettres françaises sont à
l'honneur pour la dixième fois car saint
john perse succèdent entre autres à
albert camus françois mauriac andré gide
et romain rolland
[Musique]
dans le calme de la maison blanche
on a insisté à la première visite du
futur président élu des etats-unis 43
ans au président sortant 70 en trois
heures de tête à tête qui ont porté sur
la passation des pouvoirs de janvier
mais aussi sur la politique étrangère et
la situation du dollar
[Musique]
onze mois ont suffi pour faire sortir du
sol dans la région de beauvais
lusine de trois hectares qu'a inauguré
monsieur emile roche président du
conseil économique et qui est à la fois
la plus grande usine de tracteurs et la
plus moderne d'europe
c'est ainsi que son cerveau électronique
assure la répartition des pièces et
contrôler l'alimentation et la vitesse
des onze chaînes du convoyeur
le degré d'automation des installations
permet d'assurer un rythme de
fabrication quotidienne de 250 tracteurs
de 18 types différents et la nouvelle
usine offre un autre avantage jusqu'à
présent les importations de tracteurs
étaient en france deux fois plus
importante que les exportations en
s'installant tabouret cette nouvelle
usine peut renverser la situation
[Musique]
parmi les établissements les plus
remarquables qui composent l'art 90e'
tuberculeux de la france il faut citer
le centre héliomarin de vallauris géré
par la caisse nationale de sécurité
sociale et dont monsieur paul bacot
ministre du travail vient d'inaugurer
les nouvelles installations avec ses
terrasses aménagées en gradins sur six
étages en plein midi
c'est par excellence le centre de lélio
thérapie sanatorium médico-chirurgical
spécialement conçu pour les allonger il
possède un équipement technique des plus
complets
[Musique]
vallauris et encore remarquable à un
autre type ici en effet un effort tout
particulier a été entrepris pour équiper
se sentent aussi bien dans le domaine
des nourritures terrestres que dans
celui des nourritures spirituelles et on
a tenu à cultiver l'esprit en même temps
qu'on soigne les corps
[Musique]
bien mieux et les nombreux allongé que
compte le centre n'en sont pas exclus
on a réalisé un service de rééducation
modèle où le temps de la cure est mise à
profit pour assurer la revalorisation
culturel et professionnel des malades
enseignement professionnel théorique
mais également travaux pratiqués dans
vyver ateliers
c'est dire qu'en créant ce centre la
sécurité sociale n'a pas seulement
poursuivi une action sanitaire mais
également une action sociale et l'on
peut désigner le centre héliomarin de
vallauris comme l'un des tous premiers
établissements du genre en europe
[Musique]
une algérie déchirée cela n'apparaissait
pas ouvertement encore à une témouchent
au moment où le président de gaulle y
arriver mais les banderoles parlait et
déjà la passion suscitée des gestes de
violence
c'est là que fut la serre et la première
carte algérie algérienne
mais c'est là aussi que méprisante où
les conseils de prudence le général de
gaulle entra dans une foule dans toutes
les mains se tendaient vers lui
[Applaudissements]
même scène dans le froid et la neige
devait confirmer le geste et l'accueil
de aïn témouchent et musulmans applaudir
le général et acclamèrent l'algérie
algérienne de ce côté tout semblait
aller
alger manifestaient les activistes de
l'algérie française avait déclenché la
grève totale portes closes boutiques
fermées puis peu à peu des groupes
jeunes pour la plupart commencèrent à
tenir la rue reflétant une journée des
barricades
la force publique n'hésitez pas à réagir
mouvements sporadiques qui devait durer
toute la journée marquée par
l'éclatement des grenades lacrymogènes
et de courte bagarre
[Musique]
le tunnel des facultés réduit de
résistance aujourd'hui classique été
rapidement dégagée et le calme
un calme sans doute relatif se
rétablissait dans la soirée
le général de gaulle poursuivait son
voyage d'information et d'explication de
blida à cherchell où il allait rendre
visite au sanctuaire de l'armée
d'afrique
il retrouvait partout l'accueil des
populations musulmanes mais aussi la
présence de l'antagonisme douloureux
algérie française algérie algérienne
alger marqué cette deuxième journée par
une violence accrue barricades et
bagarres
[Applaudissements]
automitrailleuses utilisé pour déblayer
les rues cocktails molotov lancés contre
la force publique et grenades offensives
lancées contre les manifestants
[Applaudissements]
des blessés de part et d'autre
[Musique]
le troisième jour le général de gaulle
passait azzedine un village de
regroupement avant d'aller à orléans
ville et à oued fodda tout le village
était là pour l'accueillir
il semblait que seuls dans leur ville
les européens a heurté par une politique
d'un libéralisme audacieux puce bouger
généreuse illusion car au même moment
les quartiers musulmans d'alger
intoxiqué par les meneurs du fln
déclenchait une journée de brutalité à
diar el mahçoul le fln frappé les trois
coups du drame qui devait endeuillé
alger comme jamais il ne l'avait été
depuis six ans car le pillage l'
incendie et l'assassinât à l'est pendant
quelques heures se donner libre cours
[Musique]
berne le soir quelques milliers de
musulmans plus redescendre vers la ville
un bouchon de crs devait pendant des
heures les maintenir
mais le drame déjà été joueur
mais ne faut-il pas dire que ce ne sont
ni tous les européens nient tous les
musulmans qui sont descendus dans la rue
si les ultras des deux bords ont voulu
créer l'irréparable
la chance offerte par la solution du
général de gaulle doit exister encore
puisque les deux communautés algériennes
ne sont pas faite que de fanatiques et
la leçon que tirera le général de cette
visite aux échos dramatique c'est que
sans doute tout n'est pas perdu par ce
bilan tragique de 84 morts et que devant
la persévérance et la fermeté la sagesse
de l'armée et le bon sens des deux
peuples
la folie ne peut pas avoir raison
[Musique]